what do you think of my my assessment
there that the air to Kobe that the guy
that should be at the top of that list
is Kawhi Leonard Chris it's uh
interesting a prize like that I think
that you know you're right about this
clearly a two-way player in it in his
prime Kobe was a great defender in all
league level defender um I think
offensively while Kawhi Leonard is Kwai
Leonard has become a dynamic two-way
player he is not the versatile offensive
player I think Kobe had more weapons
more ways to beat you than Kawhi does
nobody imagined when the Spurs drafted
Kawhi Leonard they didn't imagine that
he would evolve into this kind of
offensive player this key was a non
shooter who's become a very accurate
three-point shooter and clearly he's you
know that you know along with LaMarcus
Aldridge the cornerstone guy for them uh
you know he'll never be certainly the
dynamic personality that Kobe is nobody
nobody even knows nobody knows what I
sounds like because he he doesn't talk
uh it doesn't even talk to his teammates
he he just he just comes and he goes to
work every day and they love him I
always tease RC Buford it was like you
guys built him in your basement in the
spring he was the perfect spurry says
nothing he does everything yeah I'm with
he's not the dynamic player that Kobe
was immediately out of high school you
saw that skills but man he works and you
know this he works so hard at his game I
can see him developing a post game
averaging 25 26 being in the MVP
discussion every single year in winning
and that's what you know Kobe is great
because he was back the basket player he
emulated Jordan but Kobe won and that's
what Mako be Kobe no question and quite
Leonard's in an organization uh in a
system there were as long as RC Buford
there certainly is on his great Popovich
is there you know they're gonna have an
opportunity to be very very good in you
know you've got you know Spurs now are
really certainly building around Kawhi
Leonard in LaMarcus Aldridge going
forward and you know they're the
cornerstone guy
eyes of that organization and that makes
a big difference to be seen is that
elite level player you've got to be in a
place where foremost Yorker anyway no
nobody wins the entire way Kobe showed
that its organizations fall off and uh
even the great ones you know struggle to
the great organization struggle to stay
a contender every year Spurs have been
able to do it the Lakers did for most of
Kobe's tenure that that makes a big
difference in this conversation today
that you're winning I will get to the
coaching jobs that are open woods but I
want to start with the coaching job
there right now is not open and that's
in Los Angeles with the Lakers and Byron
Scott we've been hearing rumblings for a
while that you know the improbable
scenario at least seen that way at
midseason Byron Scott could be back as
the head coach of the Lakers next year
do you think the lakers bring him back
if they do why well it's it's trending
that way now Chris but it can change
because of the volatility of the
ownership dynamic there in the buss
family I reported you I guess was
yesterday you know that Byron Byron's
got a player of excuse me Byron's got a
team option on his on this year's deal
so the team's got a Lakers have to pick
up the option it's not a guaranteed this
the third year fourth year of his deal
are not deals are not guaranteed so
they've got a decision to make as of
right now I'm told that there's too much
of a log jam there's not enough
consensus within the group there to make
a change and then uh you know then to go
forward with trying to decide who that
next GM or see that next coach would be
if they want to make a change they've
got to do it now if they want to get
into a competitive a very competitive
coaching environment right now where you
know Tom Thibodeau is available Jeff Van
Gundy's available Scott Brooks is
available if they want a chance at one
of those coaches they've got to move
quickly so the longer they wait the more
tells you they're not doing something
that could change this afternoon with
them but as of yesterday uh they were
you know they weren't ready to make that
move yet and uh again some of these
elite coaches may go off the board
relatively relatively quickly and the
longer the Lakers wait
year they're gonna get left out of
having a chance uh because they would
have a chance at time too but oh they
would have a chance at jeff van gundy in
in uh in Scott Scotty Brooks those guys
would would and will have interest in
the Lakers job and they don't have
interest in all the jobs that are
available out there on the market right
now but the lakers even in the state
they're in um even in the total rebuild
their in all those coaches believe that
if you get in there and you can sell a
program you can get into free agency uh
and have some success because players
still want to play for the Lakers how
they resolve the D'Angelo Russell
situation it it seems the simplest thing
to do if they can't find a trading
partner for Nick Young is just cut him
and eat the money Nick has not been a
productive player for them for this year
doesn't figure be part of their team in
the long term anyway but is there a
danger was that that sends the wrong
message that the guy that caused the
problem is kept and the guy that was
negatively affected by the problem is
waived for the sake of chemistry Chris
there are no messages in the invaders no
right message there's no wrong message
it's it's who are we invested in and
they're invested in D'Angelo Russell
he's the number two pick in the draft
from last year he's the guy they want to
build around and he's the guy they have
to make it easier for so whether it's
his fault or not his fault clearly he's
the one who made the mistake here uh I
think that they're going to clean this
up by making it as easy as they can on
him I I don't see a scenario where Nick
Young is back with that team and you
like you said there's different ways to
move him either whether it's gonna be
trade was I have to wave them but I
don't see a scenario where he's back
they really kept them away for the team
here down the stretch he didn't play and
they've got to figure it out with the
Angelo going forward they invested a lot
in him by choosing him over kristaps
porzingis over jahlil okafor they've got
to make it work they've got to make it
easy for him as possible and whatever
message it said that's their priority uh
and i think that's the direction lakers
are going with this we're talking agent
one else get the editor the vertical /
yahoo sports you can follow him on
twitter at was vertical NBA on paper
woods
it looks like the the Timberwolves are
maybe the best available job out there
their president job is open your head
coaching job is open it's a Minnesota
market but it is there going to be a
fight for that job will you we see that
the top coaches actively seek it out or
something different no you're exactly
right Krista that is the job that all
the coaches the coaching agents are
really focused on because of listen
there's a great young core in Minnesota
this a really good young pieces people
like but the coaches out there right now
potential executives uh who might go
into that go into the organization to is
in the front office karl-anthony towns
if they see call anthony towns as a
future most viable player in the NBA is
a guy you want to build everything
around his talent his motor his
character uh-uh he's really benefit for
having Kevin Garnett around him this
year III talked to members of the staff
in Minnesota and they just can't say
enough about how pounces embrace having
Garnett and how Garnett has pushed him
and taught him to be a pro taught him to
be the first guy there every day if you
want to be the leader this team you
gotta be the first guy to work every day
in towns has been that and so the
question would go on Taylor to me is he
willing to pay she willing to pay the
market price for Jeff in ghundi for Tom
Thibodeau uh and if he is you know they
did pay flip saunders in that five
million dollar a year range uh and he
had the duel piles of coaching president
and and was gonna have an ownership
stake so uh if he's willing to do that
they're gonna get who they want because
uh from a talent point of view i don't
think the market matters it matters a
lot less the people that ever has that
they know you can win anywhere and
you're gonna win with call a penny
counts as your center before let you go
woods uh the perception of Cleveland is
that if this goes according to script
they get to the finals they lose in the
finals we could see significant changes
there dia is that is that perception
close to reality do you think is this an
extremely important postseason for the
Cavaliers no it is Chris and we know how
this goes if they don't win they're
gonna be scapegoats and we know who
scapegoats not going to be it's not
going to be LeBron James's fall
it's going to be whether it's Kevin Love
Kyrie Irving pilou there will be people
to fall there will be people to take the
hit if they don't win it and there will
be changes that's you you can be assured
of that and so they they ran David Blatt
out he was the first fall guy now who's
the next one going to be is it going to
be Kyrie is it going to be Kevin Love
because there will be one great to visit
with you whoa Jaya preciate the time
Chris dr. tuna that's a Georgian house
key NBN are over the vertical at Yahoo
Sports the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience